so I'm currently balls-deep and wedding
planning I just got engaged a few months
ago and yes my dog was the videographer
of the engagement so now we're trying to
decide which wedding traditions we want
to include in our ceremony so I decided
to do a little research and now I'm just
gonna go let him know what I learned
yeah do you know the origin of
bridesmaids I do not it turns out
bridesmaids were originally told to
dress similarly to the bride in order to
confuse exes or evil spirits Wow really
taking a bullet for your best friend Lee
so in the Roman Empire bridesmaids would
accompany a bride if she had to travel
to another town or village where the
groom lived and this larger party was
thought to keep the bride safe from
attacks by robbers or kidnappers if
bridesmaids are just basically decoys
for evil spirits or kidnappers then what
are groomsmen what do you think the best
man's about do you know origin on the
best man already that's right okay good
the best man actually is the biggest and
strongest friend in some cultures men
would kidnap or steal their bride you
were the best man if you were the
strongest and you were the most skilled
in fighting you were supposed to help
the groom combat anyone who opposed the
bride being kidnapped the best man
actually stands next to the groom during
the ceremony to make sure that the bride
doesn't run away cuz if the bride tries
to run away that best man he's gonna
grab her she can't run what a swell guy
do you know the origin of white wedding
dresses I thought it was some kind of
symbol of purity the wedding dress was
actually meant just to be ostentatious
and to show off wealth in 18th and 19th
century washing was done painstakingly
by hand so to have an immaculate white
dress that was only for the very wealthy
red actually was the common color of
wedding dresses before Queen Victoria so
Queen Victoria got married in 1840 and
before her
well did not wear white to their
weddings she wanted to wear white nobody
thought it was a good idea she did it
anyway every was like oh my god that's
so cool it makes you look so wealthy and
now everyone's done it for the past 290
years
hey Mike why do you think Brides always
carry a bouquet of flowers down the
aisle they're pretty in there good luck
or something Oh some ancient Greek
Brides would wear wreaths of mint and
marigold that were meant to serve as an
aphrodisiac Brides would also use
clusters of herbs to ward off evil so
there you go again with the evil people
back in the day we're very afraid of
evil spirits and they did not want them
at their weddings the bridal veil what
do you think that's about yeah like if
the husband saw the bride's face before
the veil was there like you it turned
his stone on his wedding day or
something actually comes from the
tradition of arranged marriages in some
cultures the veil was meant to hide the
identity of the bride from their groom
in Greece the veil was typically yelling
in Rome it was usually red they were
both meant to represent fire and also
fend off those evil spirits hey Lucy
what do you think the origin of the
honeymoon is interesting actually the
honeymoon also is very creepy origins
and some say it dates back to when
marriages were created by kidnapping oh
my god there's so much stuff about evil
spirits and kidnapping in this so the
husband used to have to hide for about a
month after the kidnapping to prevent
the woman's tribe from rescuing her so
her family you know after a month they
basically just like gave up looking Mike
what about the origin of wedding rings
what do you think it was probably some
kind of like symbol of ownership it was
it was some of ownership historically
the bride's ring was meant to signify
ownership so the development of the
bride and groom exchanging rings was a
result of the advancement of women's
rights not only do they own us but we
own them the significance of the fourth
finger is because it was believed to
have a particular vein that led to the
heart so in Latin was called the vena
amoris
which means vein of love that was
incorrect there is
a vein in that finger that leads to your
heart but it's all about the symbolism
isn't it folks what about the father
giving away the bride
apparently she was property so yep so
the father giving away the bride
symbolized the transfer of ownership of
the bride's property from her father to
her new husband's what is the origin of
the first kiss first kiss I mean I think
the first kiss was just pretty
significant just like we're people not
supposed to be hooking up before the
wedding
Beca no that's not at all it was once
custom for a priest to give a holy kiss
of peace to the groom and then the groom
would pass the kiss onto the bride and
then the clergyman would kiss all the
bridesmaids and the groomsmen so like
everyone just was kissing we're all
passing kisses around obviously mano
wasn't a thing back then do you think we
should do that it was certainly shock
our family which wedding traditions do
you want to keep now that you know I'll
be originated I want to keep all the
ones that protect us from evil spirits I
don't want any evil at my wedding but
really I feel like I don't want to do
most of them now I don't know they all
just seem very antiquated you don't have
to do them if you don't want to like
Queen Victoria everybody at the time was
like oh my god but now everyone copies
her so start your own trend and wear a
jumpsuit or wear a red dress like
literally the rest of the world but what
about when they're all my family's
traditions
okay I don't think that's true should we
have a best man or a best dog okay we're
gonna we're gonna okay I promise
Hey